alors la silicon valley qui va visiter
le chef de l'état c'est le creuset de la
technologie de pointe américaine c'est
là que sont nées les grandes trouvailles
l'informatique
c'est une sorte de ville industrielle
consacrée à la performance
on y trouve environ 500 entreprises
réparties de part et d'autre de
l'autoroute qui relie san francisco à
los angelès georges leclercq nous fait
découvrir cette cité où le futur rejoint
le présent silicon valley vient du nord
c'est le cas en france et silicium
qui est le matériel de base des circuits
intégrés
est ce cette plaquette
cette plaquette contient à peu près 11
200 circuits intégrés ils contiennent
chacun environ 500 transistors au départ
la silicon valley c'est le paradis de
l'électronique de l'ordinateur du laser
bref de tout ce qui symbolise le progrès
dans le progrès scientifique mystérieux
de laboratoires non le progrès
quotidiens celui qui entrent chaque jour
davantage dans votre foyer
dans votre cuisine dans votre salon en
plus ce n'est pas uniquement le progrès
technique c'est aussi le progrès humain
le progrès social les gens que l'on
rencontre dans la silicon valley semble
différent plus épanouie
souvent ils ont quitté une condition qui
ne le satisfaisait pas pour chercher
fortune ici un peu comme l'ont fait il
ya cent ans les chercheurs d'or
allié à peu près 12 ans
est ce que vous faisiez avant en france
eh bien lorsque j'étais enfant j'étais
standardiste réceptionniste
géographiquement la silicon valley c'est
une énorme concentration d'entreprises
de toutes tailles propre non polluante
un peu futuriste d'aspect l'exemple à
suivre
le but à atteindre ici c'est l'employé
qui devient millionnaire en créant sa
propre entreprise
c'est justement le code stylet jeune
inventeur de micro-ordinateurs à pau
avec steve wozniak ont travaillé dans
des sociétés d'électronique
nous voulions utiliser un ordinateur
individuel ce qui existe à l'époque du
moins mais on ne pouvait pas acheter un
cd trop cher alors on en a imaginé un
jeune acheter les pièces et on la
fabriquer nous mêmes la créativité le
goût du risque n'explique pas tout la
silicon valley c'est un phénomène
complexe où l'homme est l'essentiel bien
sûr mais seul il ne peut pas tout faire
andré c'est quoi les ingrédients la
silicon valley les ingrédients sont
d'abord un climat très agréable
ensuite la disponibilité de personnel
technique très qualifiés très capable et
aussi la disponibilité de capitaux qui
permette fonctionnement d'une industrie
avec ces ingrédients la silicon valley
ne se contente plus de l'électronique et
des ordinateurs
tout ce qui est d'avant garde tout ce
qui peut faire gagner de l'argent
intéresse les habitants de la vallée